right thank you david uh let's move on
to the
third talk of the sessions uh sorry for
delaying this both the speakers had to
leave
and couldn't be part of the discussion
so that's why we
chose to take questions i i hope negan
you didn't mind
don't worry about it so yeah without
further ado
uh let's uh have negan from the sloan
school of management at mit
talk about her work on online markets
thank you so much cheaper also first and
foremost i want to
thank the organizer and in particular
shibra for the invitation and thank you
guys for attending the talk
uh today i'm going to talk about online
learning with offline greedy
and the offline 3d algorithms and i'm
going to talk about
some of the application in market design
and optimization that
fits our framework and this is a joint
work with my great quotas the
headquarters rod
and joshua my phd student and francisco
susan and
ashley uh okay so uh
so i'm gonna start with motivating this
work uh
can you guys uh see the second slide i
think that there's a light
no we cannot see the second slide yet
i cannot at least i don't know about
others yeah i think
yeah i think that you guys cannot see it
i don't know exactly why
so let me stop sharing and start sharing
again because there might be some
issue
okay so
hopefully you can see it now can you
yes yeah
okay so then uh uh so
i'm gonna talk about so let me motivate
this work and uh by talking about
decision making marketplaces
so uh if you think about marketplaces
they have to make certain decisions
repeatedly over time so think about uh
online retail stores uh
for them like on a regular basis they
have to
decide about what items they want to
offer to customers in order for example
to maximize their market share
so another example is a product ranking
that in
product ranking we want to the problem
is that hobby are going to display the
products
um on online platforms in order for
example to maximize consumer engagement
and it turns out this is an important
problem for the online platforms because
as a human we tend to look at the
products that are more visible to us
and as a result how and in what order
products are being displayed is going to
influence uh
the customer's decision and as another
example we have um
reserve price optimization so think
about
and running second price auction in
display advertising market to sell
ads and in that scenario one of the
important
parameters that needs to be optimized in
order to maximize revenue is
reserve prices so uh for all
of these uh problems uh and we face a
few like fundamental challenges so the
the first challenge is that
in these decision making processes we
have a lot of uncertainties
so think about astronomy planning uh uh
as a
um as a retailer i don't know the
customer's demand in advance
so for product ranking i don't know how
customer how patient the customers
are gonna be and how many products they
end up looking at
to make it purchase and then for reserve
price optimization
i don't know the advertising willingness
to pay and on top of that
and the environment under which uh read
on
the underlying environment under which
i'm making a decision can be
time-bearing
so for assuming planning demand can
change over time so maybe before kovid
people had the
different demand function i know after
covid people are actually
interested in buying different things
and uh for product ranking the same
thing
there may be customers in before covid
would like to spend more time on online
platforms with not mine
i did not mind actually spending a lot
of time uh
browsing but then after covington maybe
they'll get busier
and for the price optimization we have
similar challenge
but these two challenges are not the the
only challenges that marketplaces face
there's another important challenge and
maybe the most important challenge here
is that
let's assume that i don't have any
uncertainty whatsoever
then the underlying offline problem that
we need to solve in these decision
making processes
is going to be np hard to solve so
roughly speaking this is the case
because i have too many options to try
so when i'm offering a solo planning my
options is the number of sets that can
be like exponentially large
so given these motivating examples and
given these main challenges
here are two main research questions we
want to understand
how to design learning algorithm for
such combinatorial and timeline
environments
and in particular we want to know if we
can transform
offline algorithms to the online
algorithm with sublinear approximate
regen
can we transform offline algorithms to
get good
learning algorithms and the answer to
this question
and based on this work is that yes for
otherwise i wouldn't be talk
i wouldn't talk about it so the answer
is yes because for a large class of
offline problems that admit a robust
greedy algorithm with constant
approximation factor
we are going to be able to do this
transformation
and in fact for all of these three
examples that i talked about
there exists a greedy algorithm and and
all these great algorithms are
robust and i'm gonna explain what we
mean by being robust
and uh and also they give us constant
approximation factor
so in the rest of the talk what i'm
gonna do i'm going to use assortment
planning as the running example to
illustrate our technique
but then our technique can be applied
for other and other examples that
i talk about product ranking and reserve
price optimization
okay so let me start with preliminary
uh and i'm gonna walk you through the
offline problem and remember that my
focus right now is gonna be on just
simply assortment plan
so what's the problem i have n products
and my goal is to choose set s with a
cardinality at most k
that maximizes market share which is
just simply the probability of purchase
and i'm going to use this uh f of s
to the to denote the market share or the
demand on their settings
and for many i think for those of you
who know about choice modeling so for
all the random utility choice model this
f function is simply a monotone and
submodular function
so as a result my offline problem can be
simply
be maximizing a monotone submodular
function with cardinality constraint
so this is the offline problem that i
have here and and then the offline
problem and
it's a greedy algorithm with um with the
approximation factor of one minus one
over e and this is a
i'm sure that most of you know about
this result is a classic result by
number sorry at all
that they design include the algorithm
with this approximation factor
but uh let me walk you through this
algorithm because
then later i'm going to build intuition
based on this greedy algorithm
so the way that this grid algorithm
works is that
it has k sub problems at every sub
problem it's going to choose a product
zi
that maximizes the
that maximizes the marginal um market
share
right so that's a and then this is the
what i mean by marginal market share
this is the
the market share that you have at the
chosen set when you add product i
and this is a market share at the
previously chosen set so to the
difference in the marginal and i'm
choosing a set
product zi that maximizes the marginal
market share
and after that i'm adding zi to my set
and at the end i'm returning sfk which
is going to be the final set i'm going
to
show to the customer and uh i think like
um one of the nice things about the
security algorithm is that
it actually builds a solution stage by
states on top of each other and that's
what i mean by degree the algorithm
so that means that when i'm like doing
building a solution and stage by stage i
do not go back and revisit my my
my decision i just build a decision on
top of that and that's kind of my
the definition of a greedy algorithm in
this world
okay now what about the online problem
so
in the online problem i have t runs and
in every rom t there is a nature and
we'll call it adversary
and it's going to choose a monotone
submodular demand function f of t
and note that this there's a index
selective here that that means that
this demand function is time varying and
also this demand function is
is not unobservable and that's indicated
that this the decision maker needs to
make a decision under uncertainty
so after adversity chooses this demand
function the algorithm is going to
choose a set
s of t and then obtains a market share
or reward of f of t at
sft and then the algorithm is going to
get some feedback afterward
and we focus on two different feedback
structure
so full information which means that
algorithm is going to observe the entire
function
and then the band need to feedback
structure which only means that
algorithm only are going to observe f of
t
at the chosen set s of t and
we have result for both of these
settings and of course valley feedback
structure is more challenging but then
to simplify the the discussion and do
they start i'm just going to focus on
the full information
feedback structure uh okay so and then
this process will continue
like from every run adversary chooses
something algorithm to the set and get
some feedback and
we have that process up to run capital c
any questions okay
there's no question uh so then uh let me
talk about the our goal here in this
world so we want to
minimize regret with respect to gamma
times opt
gamma is the approximation factor and
auth is going to be
um the maximum market share that one can
get
if er if he or she had the benefit of
the hindsight
so this is if i know all this the demand
function f of t in advance
and i get to choose one single set
having this knowledge this is the the
best
maximum market share that i'm going to
be able to obtain
and then i'm calculating the regret by
comparing
what i'm getting which is this summation
with gamma times opt and remember gamma
is approximation factor
and the reason i have this gamma here is
because the offline problem itself is so
hard and i can only get
a gamma fraction of the optimal that's
why when it comes to the regret
i'm also focusing on approximate regret
which is a very common
notion in the in the learning literature
okay so i think now this is a good time
for me like to uh
summarize the our contribution and main
result and one of the nice things about
this work is that we have it like a
general framework to transform
offline grid algorithm to a low regret
online algorithm via blackfall
approachability
and we have a result for both full
information setting and banding feedback
construction
and for a full information studying we
get over square root
gamma regress and then for the banded
feedback structure we get to the power
of two
and for the uh maximizing monotone sets
of modular function which is the running
example
for the full information we can match
the best uh prior bond in the literature
and then for the bandit by the structure
we improve it uh the
improved the best product on the
literature but i think i don't want to
say that this is kind of the main
contribution of this work
because the main contribution is the
fact that our framework has a wide range
of applications and can be applied
to a variety of settings so here's a
list of application that we try in our
paper and we
we believe that there are more so uh we
apply to product ranking problem like
reserve price
optimization non-monotonous that's a
modular function
non-monotone strong dr submodular
function and non-monotone weak dr
modular function so um so uh
uh and then in all of these cases either
we matches the
uh the best prior bond or improve that
or we are the only one like that
provide a bond for this problem so uh
let's look at the results so for the
full information setting
we always get in terms of dependency in
t we get a square root t dependency
and in for the bandit so we get to the
power of two third dependency if our
decision set
is discrete for example for product
ranking so ranking something discrete we
get to the power of two there
but whenever like the the decision said
is become um
continuous in that scenario i think
there are some questions here
oh uh so good question are there any
lower bonds
for these problems um i think like
uh as far as i know for example for
uh i'm not aware of like in terms of the
dependency on t i think for full
information square it is
is tight for the bandit feedback
structure i don't know if it is tied but
then as you can see
this is kind of like in majority of
cases we all outperform the best known
bond in the literature
thank you for your question uh so uh
then
for the continuous case because for
example for a surprise optimization
we need to uh uh for um we need to also
do discretization and discretization
is gonna because of this criticization
error our regret one is gonna get
a little bit worse we get to the power
of four fifth and um
a couple of things that i want to
highlight is that
if you think about the bandit feedback
structure and the bandit feedback is
structured capture more realistic
scenarios
but then you don't see and it's also
more challenging to uh
um to attack but uh you we don't see a
lot of
prior result in the literature and we
are very excited to see that um
we are very excited to see the result in
the literature to contribute to the
literature by providing
uh bond for the vanity packet structure
i think for some reason uh you guys
don't
see that again i think my my
my video card is not there to share
anything
sorry
are you using ipad or who's your ipad
yeah sometimes it freezes actually
okay so now i think like i also want to
talk about the
uh related work and kind of to put into
context to say
how this work contributes to offline to
online transformation for np-hard
problems
uh i think the first and foremost
there's this negative result in the
literature saying that
uh for general combinatorial problems
you cannot get
um sublinear regret okay so and that
kind of justifies that why in this world
we focus on a class of um np-hard
problems that
they're amenable to um some guilty
algorithm with approximation
with constant approximation factor and
and there's also
like a nice word by colombo 2005 and
dude 2017 that they
provide the algorithm based on follow
the perturbator and they
their approach only works if you can
solve the offline problem efficiently
but for our case this is definitely not
the case because we are dealing with np
heart problems
and for uh and then there is a and a
great word by kakade all that they show
that if they
if the npr is and they can handle
anti-hard problems but then for them is
very crucial to have linear rewards
which is again this is not the case even
for the maximizing submodular function
there is also a large body of literature
and combinatorial learnings
and then for combinatorial learning i
think this literature is pretty mature
but the focus is on linear reward
structure which is not the case for us
so our contribution is that we focus on
uh
np heart problems with a non-linear
reward structure and
and then we handle both banded and full
information setting
and we were able to transform offline
grid algorithms to their online
counterpart
that gets sublinear regret
okay so now i think like we are getting
to the exciting part
part of the thought like talking about
high level ideas and presenting the
algorithm
uh okay so to explain the high level
ideas i'm just gonna
first revisit the greedy algorithm
present some of the properties of the
greedy algorithm
and then based on that i'm just going to
tell you about the high level idea and
present our algorithm so
if you remember the algorithm has k sub
problems
where in sub problem i we choose the
product zi
that maximizes the marginal market share
and dels if and i just introduced new
notation just to make
everything simpler now i'm going to say
the fact that the greedy algorithm
chooses such product
is equivalent to this payoff vector to
be greater than equals 0.
so let me walk you through these kind of
parse this vector for you
and look at the first element so if you
look at the first element this delta f
of z i
is the marginal market share at the
product that the greedy chooses
and delta f of like one is the marginal
market share
of the product one and this should be of
course greater than equals zero
because the difference between these two
because the greedy algorithm chooses the
product zi that maximizes the marginal
market share
and then the same thing following the
same logic you can say that
all these like elements in this vector
should be greater than equals zero
and then this is equivalent to say that
the greedy algorithm chooses the product
of the i that maximizes the marginal
market
so but then there is like a minor issue
here like it's nice that i wrote this
condition later you will see this why
this is nice to write it as this
this form but there's a minor issue that
this vector payoff is not
linear in the greedy's decision zi and
i'm just
i need um you're going to find out why
this is important i'm just going to do
it like a simple trick to make it linear
and then after that talk about another
property of the greedy algorithm
so the trick i'm gonna do is that for
sub problem i
uh instead of returning the product vr
i'm gonna return a distribution theta i
over the end products that i have
and then what is this distribution let's
say i only have
one product only one product that has
the highest marginal market share
and then in that distribution i just
simply put the mass of one for that
product
and put it like zero for the rest of it
okay nothing major is the same thing
but then now let me write this vector
payoff in terms of theta i
so if i do that if you think about the
yellow part that i highlighted
this is the expected value of the
marginal market share at the greedy
solution
right and uh and and then again by the
same logic i know that because
the algorithm go with a solution that
maximizes market share this vector
payoff that i defined
is going to be again greater than equals
zero
and now why i did that because now all
of a sudden the vector payoff is linear
in the greatest decision theta i which
is a nice property to have
okay so uh now uh let me also talk about
the
a very nice property of this gradient
algorithm and and in fact i'm going to
show you that this credit algorithm is
robust
to local errors so what does it mean
let's say i have an errorless system and
for every
subproblem i and every coordinate j i
manage to make sure that this vector
payoff that i have
at the solution that i'm returning for
every element j
is going to be greater than equals here
then by non-headers it will
result we know that if you satisfy that
you are going to get 1 minus 1 over the
approximation fact
so that's what i mean by errorless
system now let me add a little bit of
error to the system
in a sense that instead of theta i i'm
going to replace it with this noisy
version t
tilde such that if you look at the
payoff vector
the t tilde and you get like any j
coordinate
this this may not be exaggerated and
equal zero as i wish for but then with a
little bit of error
this epsilon with a little bit of like
um error epsilon
is still gonna be greater than equals
zero okay so that means that i satisfied
uh condition that i have over there like
kind of approximately with some error
so if i guarantee that the gray i i i i
satisfied this condition
so then the greedy algorithm the
solution that greater algorithm is going
to return it's not going to be too far
from
gamma approximation it's only going to
be epsilon times k
away from the from the
from the gamma approximation which is a
great thing because white is great
because greedy algorithm beats solution
on top of each other
right so i want to make sure that if one
of the in one of the stages i have some
error so the error does not propagate it
just simply adds up together
and it turns out that this greedy
algorithm already has that property
in the greedy algorithm this 3d
algorithm the local errors do not work
which is quite nice but that's not all
in fact like this query algorithm is
amazing that in a sense that
it's extended robust so uh
think about like a noisy run of this
algorithm over t runs
and let's say that for every round i
have like a
noise and i'm returning some noisy
version of theta i t
and then this the noisy version satisfy
this inequality that if i add up this
vector payoff across all the time
periods
and look at the coordinate j with a
little bit of error which is a function
of t
is going to be this is going to be
greater than equals zero let's assume
that i satisfy this condition
that with a little bit of help with the
little error of t i satisfy
this inequality not in that scenario
it is guaranteed that i can satisfy this
inequality
and what is this uh this is what your
algorithm gets
uh this is a gamma times what the
optimal get this is kind of the
benchmark because
s can be any set including the optimal
and this is kind of the regret part this
how far you are from then
how far you are gonna be from the from
the benchmark
and and at a high level it means that if
the aggregate error
over t runs for every coordinate it is
still a small
the algorithm is still going to do well
and in other words the error again is
not going to propagate
uh if the algorithm satisfy this
property we are going to say that this
is extended robust
and not every the algorithm is going to
have that property but there as we are
going to
i'm going to show you there as there are
many um
greedy algorithm that has that that
property
okay so now i think this is kind of
maybe the most important of the
most important uh slide of this this
talk
i'm gonna talk about our high level idea
so remember for the offline problem uh
for every sub problem i
i wanted i return a distribution theta i
such that this
vector payoff at the theta i and this
delta i have become greater than equals
zero so that's what i wanted to do
now for online problem of course i don't
know the demand function f of t
and still i need to make a decision what
i'm gonna do
i'm making i i want i'm interested in
making sure that in sub problem i
i return some kind of noisy version of
theta i
such that if i'm adding up all this
vector payoff and look at coordinate j
with a little bit of help like of error
rot
with a little bit of error i'm gonna
still be starting making sure that this
is gonna be greater than equals zero
okay and why this is good this is good
because
if i make sure error of t in the order
of square root t
by extended robustness property it is
automatic that i'm going to get a square
root gamma ray
okay so isn't it amazing just by
satisfying making sure that every
subproblem
i can be done with um kind of manageable
error in the order of
square root t by extended robustness i
automatically i'm going to get a square
root t gamma ray
and that's kind of the whole idea but i
think there's a main question here how
i'm going to design an algorithm for
every sub problem that
that with the error of t in the order of
square root t
and the answer to that question in the
blackwell approachability so we are
going to use the likewise
approachability to handle that
and let me walk you through the
bilateral approachability and i'm sure
that some of you have seen that
is a two player zero sum game with a
vector value reward
in every rounty the play two players
play and their actions
p1 obtains some reward and then p2
obtains the negative of that
two things that are important reward is
vector valued then reward vector is
going to be by a fine
so in the blackwell game p1 wants to
approach a convex set
and p2 does not want this to happen
and uh and we say convex that is
approachable meaning that player p1 can
get close to that
if the resistor for player p1 there is a
strategy that no matter what p2 does
the distance between the average vector
and average
vector value reward and set s is going
to be less than g of t where g of t goes
to zero as t goes to infinity so that
means that i'm just
as a player one it gets like closer and
closer to
to set s as t goes to infinity and
but of course not every target that is
going to be approachable and there are
simple
things that simple tests that you can do
to see if this is approachable i'm not
going to bore you with that
but what is important is that if s is
approachable
you can approach it with this rate 1
over a square root of t
and there are algorithms that allow you
to do that and i'm going to call this
algorithm algb
this is the bilateral algorithm that
helps you to approach this
target approachable set with this rate
of 1 over square root
okay so let me go back to our high level
idea
so uh remember i wanted to make sure
that error of t is going to be in the
order of a square root t
the way i make this happen is that
by letting alec be algorithm this
platform algorithm handle
every sub problem so this is the way i'm
gonna do that
and if this is the case i need to define
some like black field game for every sub
problem i
which is uh which is doable player p1 is
gonna be the algorithm
player p2 is going to be the adversary
which returns the delta
l there is a vector playoff vector which
is exactly which is by affine
due to this because of the
transformation id and that's the reward
vector in the blackfield game
i have a target set which is the
positive order because i want to
approach that set which is approachable
and then if this is the case the
argument allows me to approach that set
with the rate of 1 over square root t
which is correspond to error time in the
square root t
right so i think kind of is magical so
then i would able to
uh by handling every sub problem with
the blindfold game i would be able to
get error term in the order of a square
root t
so let me put everything together every
sub problem is being handled by a
bilateral game so i have a b1 and b2
etc so after that they
they make a decision pass their decision
through the greedy algorithm
and then after i'm getting a feedback i
pass the feedback to them
they obtain them themselves and then um
and then i know by this i know the error
term for the add b is gonna be in the
order of a square root t
and then because of the extended
robustness if i if if i have this
consider all the error terms of
different i'll be algorithms these black
algorithms the total regret pawn is
going to be k times that
because the error does not prove back
and kind of that's the gist of the
algorithm
and in fact we can go beyond assortment
planning
uh if i think if i have a
greedy algorithm that is extended robust
meaning that the error does not
propagate and it's blackfield reducible
in the sense that for every subproblem i
can define a blackfield game
with by affine vector payoff and be the
approachable target set in that scenario
i'm going to be able to get a square
root theory
and it turns out that for many of these
problems that i talk about product
ranking there are greedy aliens the
price optimization now monotone sets of
modular function and
uh for continuous it's a modular
function there exactly the algorithm
that
has this old property extended
robustness relax reducible
and then by applying our framework to
these settings that's the result we are
getting and let me highlight that
i think the result that we get for
continuous so modular function is quite
interesting because for
weak dr there was no result in the
literature prior to this word
and then for the strong dr we
significantly perform outperform the
existing bond even in terms of the
approximation factor
so we get one half approximation factor
and which is the best thing
and then they get one full uh okay so
um uh let me um
wrap up uh so today talk about and
transforming offline grid algorithms to
their online
counterpoint using blackboard
approachability so
uh we we need to create the algorithm to
be extended robust so that when we build
a solution on top of each other the
error does not propagate too much and
that assumption is satisfied by a many
creativity algorithm
and we want the gritty algorithm to be
black for reducible so that for
every sub problem we can define a black
field game and
let the black game handle that
particular sub problem
for full information studying we get a
square root of regret and for the bandit
we get to the power of two there
and we show that our framework is
flexible and can be applied to many
applications including product ranking
reserve price optimization
and sub-modular optimization we are
hoping that people can find more
application
and thank you so much for listening to
my talk this is the link to the paper
and this is my email
and i would be delighted to take any
questions
thank you
thanks again that was very interesting i
think uh
i have one quick question uh or maybe
not so quick i don't know
uh we have 10 15 minutes for discussion
since the other speakers couldn't join
for the discussion today
um my question is like can you
give a quick insight into
like what was greedy what was the
property of greedy algorithm that was
crucial here or or is it any any
algorithm that processes any offline
algorithm that processes one input at a
time
is that like a local kind of mind is is
that
yeah i think the uni yeah i think the
main thing for the main property there
are a couple of properties that we need
so the main thing is the
robustness because if you think about
the gritty algorithm
it has like several like sub problems
but you go from sub problem one to two
etc and then up to like k
and then for uh for security algorithm
let's say that in the online learning
you are not gonna
handle the sub problems uh uh
accurately so whatever like decision
you're making that's a problem
it might have like some error in a sense
that you're not going to exactly
follow the the the thing that you want
and that's another you want to make sure
that the error you are making in every
sub problem does not propagate and
become like too large
and that property is not going to be
satisfied for every greater algorithm
for example for digest
so you are not going to have this uh
robustness to local errors
so the first like main property we need
is robustness to local errors
the other thing is that the the like
when i was walking you through this uh
vector um
so um when i um
when i walk you through this um
so when i walk you through this like a
high level idea
so one thing i i need to have is that
for this sub problem i i need to define
a blackwell game for that
and then and so and that's that's also
important because i need to define some
uh by a fine vector value pair
and then i i need the uh
uh i need to make sure that they said
that there's a
convex set which is approachable in all
of our application the convex set was
just simply positive important
so as long as you have these two
properties robustness to local errors
and making sure that every sub problems
can be
handled by a blackwell game you can
define a blackfield game for that and
then
yeah you can handle it it's a problem by
blackville algorithm
we can apply our framework does it
answer your question
i think like my question is uh so these
these things you need on top of greedy
right but what if i
replace greedy but and gave you these
two properties
so i if i like is there something about
greedy that you're using for example if
i have another algorithm like say some
kind of
gradient descent or um
let's say uh frank will for something
that is
local update kind of in incremental
update kind of method that can be
applied online
uh and and you could ensure these two
properties
like is there something crucial about
greedy that you're using here
very good question i think one thing
which is um
i haven't um look into the details but i
think one thing which is
crucial here is that the number of sub
problems we need to solve for
the offline problem should be also
bonded so i don't know like for example
if you apply to the
gradient descent or merit is an
algorithm if you know exactly how many
steps you need to take for the
offline setting when you don't have any
uncertainty to reach to the
um to the point of the minimum that you
want to get
in that scenario yeah so you can apply
our framework there's nothing special
about the
uh the greedy algorithm any no local
improvement is going to be good but then
i think they have a dependency on the
number of sub problems so you need to
have
that so if you know that the number of
sub problems for the offline problem is
bonded
yeah you can you can apply that as
okay but for all of our studies if
somebody else had a question right
yeah go ahead
yep hi no no i was just saying somebody
else had a question yeah
okay okay yeah uh
i had a query um with respect to
the uh federated uh
differentiable online uh settings
and how can the biases be corrected in
them
uh okay so for federated distributed
learning
uh so every there is a every late
node is gonna make a decision on its own
and then
uh i think that probably our framework
can be applied there
and because you are going to have
limited
steps that you are going through and
then let's say you are going through
there does a step in a sequential
fashion
like for example there's not one make a
decision and then no two etc
and uh if you you kind of your last
function is robust
like if you for example node one making
a decision and then overall
and then not to also make something some
like maybe a bit like a noisy
noisy noisy decision and overall if that
error does not propagate and gets too
big it just adds up
i think that this framework can can
handle that
that's kind of like my guess
okay thanks first like it depends on the
specific problem that you want to also
make sure that
the problem that every node is solving
this sub problem
think about like what our every node
solves think either like a one sub
problem
so uh you want to make sure that this
sub problem is also black well reducible
you can
assign a blackwell to game to that so
i'm sure there might be like uh some
application on their
federated learning that satisfy that but
i i haven't looked into that that's a
good question
yep oh oh okay thanks i
got it
any other questions
sudeep do you have a question your mic
is on
oh no i i was prompted to unmute so i
don't know why that happened i had no
questions
okay okay i think like you may be a
replacement
uh i think like cheap right that you
asked some questions about the mirror
jason i think this is
interesting uh one thing i want to say
in all of the application that we
consider
the sort of stop problems that we need
to go over like in
in the offline problem is deterministic
and it's known ahead of time
and probably like in the mirror decent
algorithm you maybe
you know that with high probability with
this number of steps you're gonna kind
of converge to
uh to the solution that you want and uh
so maybe it needs a little bit of work
how to take care of the randomness and
the number of
steps that you need to make in order to
reach
reach your solution because for us the
the
everyday i'm going to consider has a
fixed number of like sub problems
and then and yeah but then potentially
can be extended
right like i think like yeah it will be
interesting see if any incremental
algorithm
uh something that processes one part of
the input at a time
not necessarily in a greedy way but
but there could be other ways to yeah to
to have an offline incremental algorithm
and yeah
that's a good question yeah this nice
structure that it's natural to take it
online
because yeah yeah
right do you have any insights on like
future
directions or things you would like to
work on
in this yeah i think like this is an
area which is
um kind of um i think has a lot of
potential because
the set of papers there is not uh
it's not huge i think like one of the
one thing that i'm interested is that is
there any another class of algorithms
that
not necessarily greedy but any other
white class of algorithms that we can do
uh the transformation and also another
thing that i'm interested
to look at is that is there like a black
wall black box
algorithm that just and it's not me
looking at the details of the algorithm
that's what i did here right so i look
at it like i'll go in the detail of the
algorithm try to define some
payoff vector for that and map it to
some blackwell game
is there like some way that i can look
at this problem in a black box
black box manner that i just um
give you like you give me any algorithm
and just i'm gonna tell you that how you
can convert it to the
to the online version instead of just
looking into details of the algorithm i
think that would be also
an interesting direction to pursue and
also like what you mentioned is also
interesting to see that
at some point i thought about it but
then i don't for some reason i kind of
stopped but
yeah i think if you uh if there are some
like
gradient-based type algorithm that you
don't know how long is going to take you
to a stop
but it has some kind of greedy nature
because you
improve your your solution a little bit
by a little
bit at the time so then can you say
something about the
the designing of the algorithm
right if there are no more questions i
think we are towards the end of the
session unless someone would someone has
any last
questions
and then i want to say thank thank you
for all the three speakers
and yeah yeah go ahead i just want to
say this paper is on there
on the review and i appreciate the
feedback
and then because it's easy to improve it
yeah if you guys have questions or if
you comment if you die just feel free to
reach out to me and
would be more than happy to receive
those people thank you
yeah thank you very much yeah it has
been a very interesting session and
i'm sure you'll uh enjoyed it as much as
i did
and uh i hope to see you in the next
session
in half an hour thank you everybody